welcome to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by Em's listen to me and listen straight
to me sixty-six percent of men lose
their hair by the age of 35 the thing is
when you start to notice hair loss it's
too late it's easier to keep the hair
you have than to replace the hair you've
lost now I want you to go to four hems
calm cuz it's a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care and sexual wellness for
men if you know what I'm talking about
him connects you with real doctors and
medical grade solutions to treat hair
loss without having to break the bank
well-known generic equivalents and
name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair fda-approved
solutions backed by science no waiting
room no awkward personal doctor visit
none of that stuff so do me a favor
order now the church family gets a trial
month two hymns for just five dollars
you heard that five dollars right now
while supplies last see the website for
full details this will cost hundreds of
dollars if you went to a doctor or
pharmacy go to hims calm slash Joey Jo
ey for him calm slash Joey Jo ey the
church is also brought to you by on it
listen you know me when it comes to
supplements I ain't blowing smoke up
your ass I go first class all the way
with reefer whatever we're doing edibles
whatever
humming good whatever we're doing so
when it comes to on it they don't play
games why cuz they got out for brain
hundred-percent money-back guarantee no
you get the product back they don't want
the product they give me the money back
if they don't if it don't work for you
who else gives you that type of deal
nobody going on a dot-com and press
ENTER CH and get your party started get
10% off the limit right the house oh
right kick this [ __ ] mule Lee Steve
run is easy in the house part two of our
little conversation we're having about
books and shitty but by the way as for a
show that's coming out called authors oh
yeah where they take just do a take on
all this we I think is interesting too
there's so many great podcast ideas that
I'd love to do you don't have the time
of course I just one with authors you
know yeah let's get like three [ __ ]
houses to either have the authors call
in and talk about their writing
experiences
that's always [ __ ] with me I've
interviewed a couple authors or two
authors on my podcast and just their
Styles and talking about what they you
know one grew up in Brooklyn this guy
Reed Coleman and just went to a public
school got dropped off latchkey kid just
started reading crime novels was his
thing and then he just started but in
college started writing shorter and
shorter crime novels and then that's
what he wants to do he's actually the
guy that's gonna write the prequel to
heat
I think it's heat right he's doing
they're doing a prequel or something
like that to heat that's crazy crazy
that's crazy that they would do a
prequel to heat when he was just a
ripoff of thief I didn't see these
nobody has nobody has because it won the
Khans Film Festival 1980 it's a movie
with James Caan Belushi's brother no
really Olsen and Tuesday well really
y'all 1980 it's one of the greatest
[ __ ] movies you you know if you watch
The Godfather
the regular Godfather the hands-on it's
a great James Caan is great mm-hmm but
if you want to learn when they put those
old pieces back in James Caan ain't that
really good nice are you talking about
somebody was a James Caan fans
okay I'm telling you that some of those
scenes he did you watch and go who who
was his acting teacher these scenes are
terrible but what they got him in The
Godfather with you on table telling them
that you know you joined the army and
all that [ __ ] you gotta hurt your dad on
all that is brilliant
but chief he just hit it out of the park
I gotta check this thing out so that
wasn't like one of them like old man's
first movies so Michael man made thief
and the prequel to Silence of the Lambs
called search of the green dragon or
something like that okay and Hannibal
Lecter was completely different yeah I
vaguely remember telling ya I that movie
was Michael Peterson Michael Peterson
went on to do a movie called to live and
die in LA it's red dragon red dragon red
dragon so if you look at the Hannibal
Lecter and they're you like who the [ __ ]
is that as a matter of fact this is
crazy because last night Silence of the
Lambs was on and and Hannibal was on
afterward and I remember thinking to
myself this guy is so good
at this role like he hit it on the
[ __ ] part in the second one when he
[ __ ] takes the guy yeah I'm not in
the building it takes his guts out
Hawkeye [ __ ] knife and his guts come
onto the phone yeah la plaza the old
soul
yeah whatever the [ __ ] it is he's a
trillion yeah [ __ ] brilliant as a
killer yeah it had done wrong it's just
gross it's just and I read that book in
prison really like I read that book
word-for-word and I see that movie and
it's the exact book there's nothing they
shot that whoever executive produced
that they cut a deal and whoever will
you off towards he said if you move it
around or [ __ ] it up it's you're done
wow this has to be it's done just like
the [ __ ] book they don't miss nothing
there's nothing at it you know when you
watch when you read Donnie Brasco
there's a whole chapter about what he
did in Milwaukee with the central mob
the people who live in Milwaukee okay
they're into vending machines there's a
whole you know when you read Goodfellas
Goodfellas is really about when you read
Henry Hills book yeah yeah yeah you read
whatever it's called wiseguy yeah when
you read wiseguy it talks about Henry
hit how Henry Hill got really in that
they took out the book of the movie his
son Paulie so he was friends alone so if
he was a kid
you follow me yeah I'm without his
friends Anthony Balsamo when he was a
kid got it so whatever Anthony got Joey
got yeah that's how they were raised so
if Paulie got a job and the beach house
in the cellar
then he took Henry Hill well yeah that's
how Henry Hill got him with the very O's
they don't tell you that in the book
they tell you in the movie they say a
complete different story
but in the moon I mean in the book they
talk about them being Busboys enough
exclusive bar on Long Island I wonder if
that's done if there's versions of the
script that are like that that have all
that stuff still in it well I have a
version of a Goodfellas script and it's
similar to the movie it's one of the
revisions on I just gave it to me as a
gift in Toronto it was a store that
there the guy who sold scripts with
signatures yeah legit this one's signed
I don't know
the [ __ ] loafers did you read it is it
similar to the shooting script or the
one that shot or no there's a couple of
things that are out of place
it's so weird haha okay because they
make adjustments as they yeah their
movie a lot of people know that you know
when I actually first got analyzed that
there was shooting that in New York
mm-hmm and I'm not kidding you guys this
is how much will but that's why when you
guys would read about a movie and then
all it made 800 million dollars and then
you go to box office mojo and you see
how much you're calling you see how much
that film cost to make and you go wow
now if that film is 180 million guys I'm
gonna tell you something at home 60
million of that is pure waste yep it's a
write-off guys it's an investment for
the movie company that's why they have
to turn that movie around so quickly
that's why it's very rare that a movie
company if we put a lot of money into a
movie the movies coming out whether it
sucks it's coming out you know don't run
it crew was different what do you call
those focus groups you get a rating will
kind of feel for it I don't even think
they're running him to focus groups
anymore they're so [ __ ] bad well the
movies cost a lot of money they're
coming out on big dates where they want
people to go see movies when you see a
movie that cost a lot of money that
they're burying at different times like
that are not popular you can tell those
are the ones they probably have listened
to even how many movies I'm making money
look what happened this little weekend
how many movies really making money
anymore
it's the Marvel movies or [ __ ] comic
books the Black Panther movie killed it
this year yeah or or it's the guys like
Seth Rogen who are doing like 15 to 20
million dollar movies that are making 60
to 70 million dollars or now a hundred
you know so now what you're doing is you
have guys that were like Seth Rogen made
a couple of movies for 15 million
dollars like The Dictator movie or
whatever that was and they probably made
about 50 now he has a budget of like 25
or 30 because those movies are making a
hundred or 120 now like the need you
know neighborhood watch and those other
movies that he's producing and directing
and stuff so he though he's got a
formula where if you don't ask for too
much up front you know you've got a fan
base that's going to build that's going
to make you now it's not going the big
exceptions are like get out
you're like Jordan peels movie that you
make for you know four million dollars
and then it makes two hundred and fifty
million dollars it gets nominated for an
Oscar I mean that that guy should he
should be able to make whatever he wants
for the rest of his life because think
about how you know how much money he
made the original and rest investments
eight million dollars I think the
shooting budget was well eight million
dollars will listen and it made it's
probably two hundred fifty million
dollars we've all we've all [ __ ] been
or been part of movies or whatever where
I've been allowed a movie you have you
got to get something there's a [ __ ]
Apple and and cheese chips those chips
with cheese in the middle processed
chips that just a six-pack yeah that's
it I bet on those movies guys right now
a hundred hours a day those movies that
I'm gonna movies where there's lots of
tales on Friday oh yeah you know mall
cop we had segways to drive around
whenever we wanted to those a little
[ __ ] the mall cop segways you want to
go together in the mall take a Segway
here's a jacket keep it don't worry
there's a Nintendo in your [ __ ] hotel
room you know and that's a little where
we get that you don't really need a
sixty million to make a movie that the
studio gives you that and you could chop
it up anyway so that's the thing that
what you have to spend it yes see that's
a thing but do you have to that's what
I'm that I think they're saying is like
do you have to spend it do you have to
buy everyone jackets and Nintendo's
instead you just go look instead of
getting that [ __ ] we're getting a
tighter budget we're gonna work a little
harder for a little shorter but instead
of that we don't have as much pressure
to make as much money you know I'm
saying the mall cops that that have that
extra budget and even for the buddy who
did the first wall cop yeah the first
word in the budget wasn't even that
mother mother it was a [ __ ] home run
it was thirty million twenty four
million dollars in January on Martin
Luther King weekend which has now turned
into a greatly great weekend
yes flopped it up would walk up huge and
it's funny because I still have a
shooting spider-man and walking on Sony
lot and walk into my room and
know what let's say the [ __ ] like and
let's say with Studio 6 my room was
[ __ ] I have my walk you know I was a
nobody
yeah there was a nice room yeah I'll
never forget walking and seen subtly and
gone what are you doing here and I'm
like I'm shooting spiral mentors I get
the [ __ ] out here I go what are you
doing haters I'm trying to get Kevin
James a film career yeah he was a TV a
DA and then he got him hit you
yep and I never forget that I will not
to dinner with Rogan and him one night I
go hey bro I get problem props to do him
and when I bumped into spider-man set
ain't gonna feel what were we talking
about he goes Captain James get in the
movie I know you got him an inch
yeah you got him [ __ ] movie will
submit that that would launch them for
[ __ ] and that he did walk and then he
did mall cop his only thing that that
was it and yeah I mean that just he's so
likable in that movie he just took off
huge numbers Hugh I'm een that was a
that made a lot of money but then you at
the other movie I did Eddie Murphy movie
it's called imagine that the mood of
shooting budgets 92 million dollars it's
made sixteen sixteen seventeen you could
look it up I think it's 17 but I mean
think about that L for Paramount think
about that L that's a big L but there's
what people don't understand that you
have all these owls but all you need is
three home runs well he's having a
hundred million dollars Eddie Murphy
Scott well yeah I know I mean so he's
got a track record of you know but you
take an L like that and a couple of
those see took a couple of us you know
or but not give a nor bit hate took a
couple beat and stand for a while yeah I
was I there's a whole crew of us that
were all in those movies we were all
thrilled it to work with Eddie Murphy
and he was they never you know who's
never really there well in the name in
the movie imagine that I think it made
17 million dollars it's 90 million the
movie business is [ __ ] yeah at the
time it was ten years ago
well I mean this rough track if you're
not anymore
feel like if you guys aren't acting in a
movie do you see more money if they sell
tickets what do you mean I'll say that
again like if you do you make more money
if they sell a lot of tickets like you
or Joey yeah and like yes for mallcop I
get residual checks movies that are
successful is actually worldwide is that
from TV or when they plan on TV and DVD
sales or is that tickets to every DVD
sales everything that's internet now
that's when they played on HBO and [ __ ]
Mike what I was thinking was it like if
they took away all those perks for you
you know that you know the studio is
making millions and millions do you
really care if you if I gave like what
do you really be like okay I'll give up
all that food or I'll give up the
Nintendo because I want to make it let
you order more bugs well here's the deal
you will if you make if you know you're
making a good movie but if you're a guy
that just gets twenty five million
dollars a check and it's just like well
what's the next script coming through
and you just do it like it's a crappy
movie like we did like Eddie Murphy well
how many times are they gotta you know
they're not gonna give you 25 million
dollars anymore to do those movies well
they might because it's a [ __ ] write
off certain amount of money to make a
certain amount of movies but I think
they'd rather give 12 kids two million
dollars to make they don't like that
that might just blow up and Eddie Murphy
1025 to be in anything they don't think
that way I don't know you've been here
for twenty you've seen it yeah they
don't think that way I just I'm
optimistic that he gonna do something
out people listen we're all like I'm
always gonna go I loved his stories
about a guy that put together a movie
for three million he had a [ __ ]
cosign his mother's and grandmother's
house I shot a movie called you got
nothing okay mmm this [ __ ] sold
the script soldiers ran some of the
attacks the whole thing he wanted play
some Russa stole his girlfriend signed
with somebody's manager Faye Dunaway's
manager you know hip pocket in her so
what did he do
this guy had done a seven episodes NYPD
blue or he had a line or less guess what
he did what like they came to him I'm
not kidding
guys they came to this is 2003 this is
the first movie I ever did that was more
than one day mm-hmm
this was the first movie I ever did that
had more than one scene and this is the
first movie I ever did with a push on a
plane and we shot in Sacramento and I
didn't have to shoot for two days and I
got a grandma bottom bar and a VFW I
went to then have a drink right I wasn't
it two minutes and some chick came up in
here like I'm below and speed give me a
[ __ ] gram of coke I was supposed to
go to rehearsal I never showed because
it was one line I told my had the flu
justice if you watch this movie dog
you're like Joey who gave that orange
shirt
I couldn't even use the scenes on my
reel do you understand me these guys had
the movie so this was a home run they
had like three people attached paramount
but the guy just couldn't let it wait
[ __ ] it no I'm gonna have my parents
[ __ ] put up they Remo give that to
Remo Remo yeah were huge they had her
parents remortgage refinance refinance
his father refinance they all do both of
them refinance their houses in Beverly
Hills leverage to the tent forget the
one guy had a wig oh my god Marie's wigs
don't feel and the one guy that I knew
from the movie was the guy that played
the sidekick in okay now this I hate
this [ __ ] sidekick and why I brought
some girls to meet you where would you
bring the regular bimbos now and I've
been bows they've been Mets Oh bachelor
party no the one with the kid from the
Beast he says Dana girl my hometown and
[ __ ] Matt Dillon Matt Dillon 1984
Hector Elizondo and thereby the kid who
league in the summer he goes up to the
[ __ ] the Flamingo okay yes oh my god
he was in the Flamingo kid so when I
went to the audition I read like oh [ __ ]
alright I love the flamingo okay yeah
that's all it takes is when a person
working all by
I was like this is legit this is legit
so I took this movie I'll never forget
the [ __ ] costume lady goes what do
you would you bring Ralphy mad give me a
shirt
it was orange one of his shirts like a
5x that didn't fit him home on that
somebody gave to him I was like a 4x at
the time coked up to the gills you know
what was in that movie to look it up you
got nothing and give me the names there
was a guy in that movie that was married
to the chick from NYPD Blue that one
that was married to Jimmy Smits on the
show the brunette oh yeah okay so this
is really beautiful you're the second
Gillian person on the other cast oh yeah
they had to move me up who's number one
Greg Lindsay okay whose no Val Lauren
guy I keep the rest is alphabetical he
breathed Philip Angelotti Benjamin
carpenter Joe Cory Cortese okay Joe
Cortez Joe Cortez Joe Cortez Joe Cortez
the story guys you're gonna die about
this one
that sounds for this guy it was a big he
still around Joe Cortez still around
about 70 looks good goes in for a few
roles from time to time how he looks
real good oh my goodness but joke what
Dez was this [ __ ] dude that in the
eighties was just a woman killer in this
town oh really
and the story goes he was Miami Vice he
got it he was the original Don Johnson
he was the original oh yeah yeah yeah
who's he with as of agency I don't have
problems on uh-oh
I should log into mind oh he died but
he's still alive he's still alive it had
a single Jersey yeah joke what does look
good had a tremendous career in this
town 72 American history acts was he in
there yeah Joe Cortez bro was a bad
[ __ ] but Joe Cortez was the
original Don Johnson Don Johnson did
walk into an audition on a Friday
I nailed it is that what happens at the
story yeah it's like you got it
Stephen is easy your other guy and then
Don Johnson walks in and I said go see
someone look just go see this guy Don
Jonathan at the time was hanging out
like what [ __ ] Frank Zappa Don
Johnson was like a go Don Johnson was
hanging out with either let it skin it
or the Allman Brothers do some revisit
this in fact one of those bands say that
he called wrote a song like Don Johnson
was like a [ __ ] actor in this town
that was just a good-looking guy but he
was [ __ ] tearing up he was married to
Melanie Griffith I think he married
Melanie Griffin's mother Don Johnson has
an interesting story yeah yeah yeah he
did some Pippi something he's [ __ ]
nuts Don Johnson really but Don Johnson
walked into that thing on a Friday and
got it and the rest was [ __ ] history
Joe Cortez that's his it's like that
dude that he turned down friends and he
looks like a dick who turned misses
there's an actor that's out there he was
in the movie with Geena Davis in 1995
with Geena Davis did with the black dude
who's the black dude that does all was
Spike Lee movies the DJ Oh Wesley Snipes
and the DJ and do the right things come
on guys because the great car
commercials now he's huge who was the
biggest black actor oh oh I'm the guy
president from 24 24
by the way Philip and Joe Cortez all
those guys we did that movie you got
nothing and I mean did it make any money
it didn't do anything nothing nothing a
lot of those movies don't it was such a
shame because what we were doing it they
kept talking about their lives and their
money and the investment they had and
they weren't trying to spend they really
were keeping the budget low I mean that
wasn't a nice hotel or something like a
motel 6 in Sacramento I was really
excited I had like eight days on the
movie yeah so it was great I know I got
the movie when I walked in there you
know it was the first time I ever
like that and then like a week later I
got the Rodney moving now which one they
were at The Comedy Store oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah I got an audition like I just
finished that and I get an audition at
right across the street from the it's
down on the block from the Comedy Store
on Sunset and it towards the strip club
I'm across from that bar so there's that
Mexican bar in the corner when you come
up that Street and make a left and then
there's the train will you get the hell
yeah yeah chill are ya honeys yeah up
the block from there used to be a
big-time casting director okay she was
old and she'd throw you out of the
office if you want but the head like the
first time I got an audition with her
they were like listen this lady is
[ __ ] a 60 thousand years old and she
doesn't even like you bringing the sides
it you gotta be off-book
it's first from the pre read those days
of the pre that was Recio you got to be
there and those days there was a pre
read yeah so you gotta go to the casting
director first before that you she puts
her she put your [ __ ] out there for
you she would reread and you would [ __ ]
and do this and then there was six hoops
and I remember I went for the pre readin
when I walked in Rodney was in there and
the pre read listen to me right he was
in there who who's the guy that runs the
Laugh Factory Jamie no in Vegas
he was the director Garrett
no no no who runs that the Laugh Factory
is uh I don't know who I just spoke to
him about a week ago two weeks ago a
great guy he put me in that movie really
he was a director he had done two movies
of Rodney as a director and [ __ ] I
walked in and I just seen him and a
bunch of those producers walk around the
store I didn't know anything about it
you seen anyone else you in the waiting
room like that like other people
auditioning like cuz usually that's like
comedians that are like just like oh
we're all going into this [ __ ] thing
together no I don't remember there were
the only other comedians in the movie
were Harlem will lives mm-hmm Paul
Rodriguez the guy with the big ears
that's a drunk that's still around I
forget what his name is
a couple [ __ ] annoying comments but
another there's no comments from the
store that like mines no no no I don't
know I went in there like god that's the
first time it's a movie about the prison
and I was one of the guys in the prison
that we went out we ran and we should we
rob the hardware store at night so we
had jacuzzis as [ __ ] bro I had scenes
with that chick the Scientologist Leah
Remini no the one that did the movie
with Travolta I had [ __ ] scenes to do
for the vacation the guy's brother I
mean that movie had oh yeah back by
midnight like my bender who's that Harry
Basil's the driver hazel Oh whose did
the movie Randy Quaid Kirstie Alley
Kirstie Kirstie Olimar
Paul Rodriguez Harland Williams Marty
Pulaski oh you know Marty Blackie yes he
was gonna be the next big [ __ ] gang
he was skinny oh my god he was a laugh
factory guy he was supposed to be a star
like Marty palatable ask Wow here's a
head shot still black and white so I
don't think it worked out ya know I
haven't seen Tony Cox Tony Cox a little
black [ __ ] yeah it's from afar my the
little black [ __ ] from [ __ ] the
movie you like wanna see part two with
Johnny Rock in his girlfriend Santa
that's insanity Cox a little black
[ __ ] oh dude he's hilarious hilarious
I mean we had a blast of that movie
Christie alley was eaten she had to be
tipping the scales the scales at 350
Gilbert Godfried was a little yeah we
were eating we're eating like animals
other than [ __ ] set it was tremendous
and I didn't they hired me but there was
no character oh really a script like it
was up to Ronnie every day it did he
just put you in scenes and stuff and
just like he guys he liked me so much
just like Irish and he's like just bring
him them yeah find something for ya so
they called me Jojo he called me Jojo
that's an Isis this is you know this is
like [ __ ] this guy was everything to
me that I had to do everything I had to
do to keep cool or other mm-hmm like
everything I had to do like when I
watched a young comedian special ability
and Kennison all those guys he's hosting
they're hilarious but he was [ __ ]
hilarious in between nice time I'm gonna
see easy money would be us in the movie
theater sneaking beers ever so the movie
started or you heard was pea beers
opening up the whole like I still
remember being excited for easy money
two weeks out
I was nervous meeting my girl my
girlfriend at the time now my wife's
father and I remember one walked in a
couple times I met him but the first
time I really spawned it we sat down and
watched back to school and we laugh at
the same time the same it's just it's
impossible not to laugh he showed me
like when we first started to first
started going to his house he like
pulled me down yet another DVR which one
back to school no no no the one with
though he's a photographer
sorry it's this time because it's funny
on so many this is it's [ __ ] just
visually it's a funny pretty funny /
human being don't you know how to lose
my mind like I saw the Murphy yeah so I
lose my mind poor morally I didn't lose
my money there's a lot of people destroy
when I first got there but here I am and
I robbed a movie and then we go go knock
on his trailer and see what he wants to
do with you and I would walk and he
never robot he was naked on the road and
[ __ ] smoking weed and the [ __ ] thing
and I'm like he doesn't have an idea
that if he told me to suck his dick
right now and horribly him like that's
how much idolized Rodney like just he
was apart yeah done like done like he
was who I was
so for six days I just got the watches
old Rodney but I didn't give a [ __ ] yeah
I didn't he was old he's gonna remember
his lines guys he would come out just to
do his lines you know like they would
yell the lines lines so they would say
but he would just he would he was old
yeah it just wasn't him he just do
movies for the check for his pension now
well he didn't start to lose 50 but he
was still smoking dope and drinking and
walking around with a robe barefoot like
he was just a [ __ ] legend and like I
talked to him a few time ago we talked
about the scenes ooh [ __ ] Jojo and
there's all gonna do is take your shirt
off
like there's one scene 1 400 pounds I'm
just sitting there with no shirt on in a
[ __ ] prison chair looking around a
loose guy huh the movie is got off oh
man and went to the [ __ ] thing that
was no like that way like I was telling
Lee next week moral Dave Labor Day was
Labor Day Labor Day I'm gonna do a
podcast with Lee and I wrote down I did
the Abe Lincoln clothes and I wrote down
since I got a little prison the good
things that did and the bad things I did
like I'd say it's like my good
accomplished me yeah my bad
accomplishments let's take your bad
accomplishments a triple
your good accomplishments but you just
did a couple good things like idea
looking at this list and going that was
a good move yeah that was a good move
like that was instant you know like now
I'm looking at what made me do those
moves and I look at the other moves and
it's just just straight-up drugs and
stupidity a drug and just being 20 yeah
and being 30 and being immature oh my
god I got a prison at 25 years old and
he you know I had been through from 16
it didn't end like it just didn't end
Prison was like the first time that
things slowed down oh I know where I'm
gonna get an apple from tomorrow and
that was the first time so when I got
out of there did you need it you think
that I need prison yeah it was even
gonna happen then or now but somewhere
it was gonna come down and it was either
gonna be a I think they've got a I did a
mistake
and I got a short sentence so I went on
with my life but in those 30 years I
just wanted to cry
you know like got married blue deserve
the divorce you know after I knocked my
wife up like I was falling apart like
most men do mm-hmm when you knock open
up those nine months a [ __ ] emotional
for a man we keep it together like I'm
having a child
yeah but beautiful something sliders his
name is Lucifer but deep down inside
you're breaking inside you know yeah
what if I slip I can't slip no there's
no more [ __ ] up the Nets gone there's
no more [ __ ] enough like that's it yeah
like every punch I throw
has to connect yep and then you gotta
pull some too
it's weird how life throws don't like it
you guys I went to the brick I went to
peas and you another one I'm waiting to
have a kid I've said this once I said
this house is like you're never ready to
have it no you're never ready to get
that big movie nope you're never ready
to get that big call from a producer to
do that big comedy show but you step up
and you cover the spread and you walk
out and go oh yeah well and we figured
it out they didn't let me see they don't
see me sweat that's the most important
thing like I look at that list and I go
oh my god I mean I don't know how I did
that I was Howard Howard but the moves
that were good was thought out I know if
they were calculated like the stand-up
what makes you get on stage the first
time pure [ __ ] stupidity alcohol and
bravado yep
you don't know why you get on stage the
first time you have no idea you know I
like I threw this poor bastard up on
stage in Chicago through my special he
did great and he never talked about it
again it was an experience it was such a
rush oh my god I know my name it's it's
it's what do you know when you get on
stage for me the only dumbest thing we
ever did it was the Adair I mean I was
I'm like I don't really want to do my
girlfriend was like I'm gonna sign you
up tonight drunk I'm like all right
let's do it
get on stage tell three minutes of jokes
people told you were funny before kind
of yeah but I feel like you're either
there's only a certain amount of people
that would ever take the risk of doing
that and embarrassing themselves that's
a small amount and then the other bad
amount anyone that's willing to do it
that's whatever willing to do it again
or multiple times that's even smaller so
it I think it weeds out real [ __ ]
quickly real quickly the people that are
like never meant to do it but that
whatever whoever is drawn to that
microphone for whatever reason mostly
it's just I yeah for me was like some
sort of false bravado thinking that I'm
funny person that I could do it and a
little bit of alcohol that's it
and going back is because I felt okay
and I didn't something about being on
stage was like oh I'm this isn't the
worst feeling in the world I kind of at
some level enjoy this are you saying
this I'm thinking about how much I
really want to hate my wife and how much
I like to stab or how much I like to do
a lot of things to my ex-wife but she
did what she had to do but I can't be
mad at her for that but she did do one
thing she [ __ ] like I kept calling up
comedy works and canceling
oh really and yeah and then one day I
told my husband she got a babysitter so
she put me against the wall yeah I'll go
down there we went got dinner it was
like a date night and I went down there
with her and I [ __ ] got on stage and
when I got off that older uh Comedy
Works is to add Nichols at the time he's
like keep doing it you got stage
presence and [ __ ] and I remember like
walking up the stairs that Tommy was
going like how I mean I keep doing this
yeah like I have a wife and a child like
what am I gonna tell him like I remember
the next couple weeks at work it was
like I hope this ladder Falls you know I
got a roofer and that would help them I
would estimate Ruth and him ago and I
got wishes ladder Falls I'd break my leg
so I could get out of roofing one
rehabilitated gonna just stand up comic
like so it's like yeah like I didn't
know how I was gonna do hmm I kept
getting on little stages when I kept
eating a bag of dicks then I went to New
York for ten days just strictly do blow
like I hadn't been in New York for six
years
I left him 85 it's 91 and I just
basically went to New York to do blow
and get him a few stages and I went to a
few places and it was kind of scary and
I just did blow I want to buy Yankee
Stadium every night and walk [ __ ] I
rented a car from Hertz it was like a
white police car you know every time I
go to the Bronx he's black people would
run away on him like no I'm not the cops
I gotta try to hide well with a white
police car oh my god was taking cash
advances on this
credit card Brenda Justice 5u9 team
percent of least of all they hit you out
that's how they first time you got a
cash advance on the credit card you're
done yeah because the tags onto
everything the 18 tags onto everything
yeah because the hundred if they're not
charging you a hundred dollars on your
credit card they're charging you 118 and
then you don't pay that and then the
interest is on 118 okay
I went but they're theirs when I got
divorced and like every credit card in
the world and I went through them like a
[ __ ] bandit the worst day I would did
was discover like I tried to reapply the
discover I got a funny I later on came
back ripped up Bush's ticket [ __ ] they
came by rip I got a Discover card
knowledge and if they gave you a t-shirt
with it like a long sleeve t-shirt and I
remember playing basketball that day and
I had to go to a class and then I had to
go do something later on I didn't want
it was all sweaty so I won't I basically
just won the [ __ ] tea I won the long
sleeve t-shirt so I signed up the card
came in the mail twelve thousand dollars
later you know they give these [ __ ]
cards to people I don't know
twelve thousand dollars and about six
years later I finally pay this [ __ ]
card off I still have this [ __ ]
t-shirt it's got a thousand holes in it
and my wife keeps trying to throw it
away you could touch that
it was a $12,000 [ __ ] t-shirt I'm
gonna be buried in that [ __ ] t-shirt
it's got Discover card on the front of
it thousand holes up the [ __ ] sleeve
and [ __ ] holes everywhere but I held on
that [ __ ] t-shirt because it cost me
12 grand the taste of 12,000 bucks guys
they said they don't they still do that
but they signed they had discover
MasterCard Diners Club all in the
[ __ ] union hall of the collar of the
college I know that's how I got as soon
as you get a loan so when you go to look
at that that intro day yeah it was the
old road ahead Hut's I couldn't believe
it I was like a kid in a candy store I
was a sieve and I just wanted a [ __ ]
t-shirt Here I am like eight G's in my
pockets of scholarship money from poor
Latinos that I'm signing up for
classes I'm withdrawing I'm cam banging
up these checks I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
acting wick don't believe you nothing
nobody knew nothing
nobody even my wife I had money coming
in from behind Scala I had a friend
that's what he specialized that you paid
him five hundred bucks and all he did
was get you scholarships and he had
lists five nickels oh I was getting
nickels I was just banging them out like
there with my money bang [ __ ] I was so
late boy then I got a dick one save 250
[ __ ] that but I gonna get a jacket I go
get a [ __ ] one of those chicken Phil
sandwiches I think three us for those
chick-fil-a's and Bowl do you think I'm
kidding but I'll never forget going to
pick up a Pell Grant only two G ones yep
they're free and I was like ah wanna get
some blowing on like god dad stays in
the visa girl monthly yeah how are you
did you get a Pell Grant yes I did
you qualify resign me up sign me up
I signed every one of those things a
week later all those cards came in the
mail with a nickel and let me tell you
something I didn't touch those [ __ ]
things didn't touch him didn't touch him
got locked up came out didn't touch him
everyone so well I gonna go no one there
was one car and I would repay it but it
would kill me that's why I didn't gamble
cuz I don't like paying that
[ __ ] on Thursday that's what
happens with a credit card you're out
spendin drinking I would go to what's
that place that gives you the bottomless
fries right I'm gonna read rod and Robin
and bold attic over the logo then [ __ ]
you up like vodka and [ __ ] gazenga
juice and ice cream I got it for like
three thousand pounds drinking ten of
those a night and putting them on my
credit cards 16 gram thousand grams of
sugar oh my god bottomless fries I used
to spend there and then the place called
the harvest I would get my credit card
and it would just be harvest our miss
harvest harvest harvest harvest
what's the harvest harvest was a vegan
joy okay that I thought was just a teen
who had meth in it
the tea would make your hair stand up
seriously I wish I was always my I was
like a cinnamon tea when they tried to
switch it because celestial Seasonings
is in Longmont Colorado
did the ball mold okay a sickly so I
guess they put celestial Seasonings in
the town got together and sign the
petition for the harvest to bring the
tea back
this is 1987 88 89 I was I went in the
harvest everyday from 1987 to about 1994
1940 everyday I wasn't there for tea the
Swiss burner looks or the Australian pet
chicken or the big vegan gazpacho
that's all I ate was the harvest hmm I
loved it that breakfast was the best
high calorie breakfast usually it was
fruit this [ __ ] frozen vanilla yogurt
it doesn't sound bad with blueberries
but a ton of granola which kills you it
was costs whispering all with two pieces
of multigrain toast and butter that's
what I would eat for breakfast every day
heavy on the bananas and the blueberries
no Kiwi no that [ __ ]
I would go in there and destroy those
things so for years I kept my credit
card you slow I didn't know but when I
got separated what do I give a [ __ ]
I started burning through those things
like a [ __ ] but the last one was
discovered discover I just took to the
cleaners because they were done with me
but I got home coked out when they start
looking through the drawers and I found
those discovered check discover checks
oh yeah they were like you could hand
you know anything whatever you get a
credit card they also send you through
blank checks oh I don't remember that
same thing as getting an advance my
buddy is dead
God was a gambler and they almost lost
the house up those checks don't give me
those check you could put whatever you
want so I waited till I was a Saturday
night ten o'clock Wow
I [ __ ] signed it for a thousand I fed
it was cleared and there was a bank of
Boulder and I had like 300 and mine I
don't even know I don't even know no I
clicked that driana had no money in my
bank and next didn't I put in the
drive-in window and usually the check
would come back in the tube and I think
they opened it up and it was a ten
hundred dollar bills I took that money
and ran what's that feeling like but I
had also taken a loan out from these
people for the Acura at the time had an
accurate car
and I had my bank loan with them so I
guess they bro Monday 905 my phone right
mr. Diaz we have bad news for you
discover the Klein that checked you
better bring back that thousand dollars
what I was like damn those being some
girls thought at that [ __ ] that poor
girls on the bus ride home thinking to
herself what happened what happens he
was coming over the slaughter line and
got me the girlfriend she ended up
sucking and [ __ ] for two days that
basically death
oh god and they were serious I never
heard the night till 12 o'clock I said I
called a lady at the bank what do you
mean you have to 12 what are you gonna
do overclock this guy was on press
charges I said okay and I [ __ ] call
the way they had the long with that I
told her what happened like it was a
mistake whenever she wasn't ready to do
that [ __ ] luck I had called it back
if you could do is tack on the thousand
we're gonna pay this cover and tack the
thousand onto your Carlo that's how
[ __ ] ballsy I was wrong so one night
I'm taking the Acura one nugget game I
get two tickets to see the Nuggets
courtside and I hit black ice and I
[ __ ] bang out those Acura rims or
$1,000 apiece
I bang out the [ __ ] Acura my I'm
driving home with a flat tire
you know me I'm lazy I'm gonna change
the thises drove more money you [ __ ] oh
my I'm making a flats on this car so
like castle the wolf that's been on the
show and like he worked he was the
general manager at the hacker place I
told him listen leave it leave the keys
in the car I'm gonna go over there one
night just take the accurate and bring
it in the house take the tires off his
switch rooms that's how crazy I was know
how it was part of my mind you did that
please I can't talk to it because people
will know I think you just cop to it no
no they say you know not necessarily
places oh it's what his [ __ ] Hall my god
and then there's no there was a
dealership up there and I was I do that
I used to go up there some call this
[ __ ] and I used to go up there at night
and I used to get Gouda cheese I love
Google cheese and crackers and freshly
squeezed orange juice no it's the third
thing with the accuracy and whether I go
let me see if the doors open and the
door was open and I went in and
Friday night I went into the dealership
this stories that sound good and I knew
where the spit box was when they have
the cash but sadly I'll give you some
here
I like clip the back it was like three
four hundred the next day they blame
this guy named David means who lived in
Florida I mean that he was a fee for the
coke fiend there was a bunch of coke
free to work that the student it was a
slash through your dealership oh my god
I got a I got higher on the Acura side
and I was fresh out of prison and I had
a big chip on my shoulder dog I was out
of control
really uh I was out of control and I was
there for a house dog I was itching for
a [ __ ] and the guy's name was Jeff
Jensen I stir him up nice his white guy
in the business and my first three days
there so three thoughts I had already
made like three grand a Curie's to have
a car called the vigor and the finance
guy was black yeah this is only involved
because the race is Pia so I used to
have a car in 1988 the nickname nickname
it was [ __ ] hilarious so one day I
found out something they were gonna
revoke my probation so so Jeff Jensen
was one of those guys that was just been
a night you don't like the guy from
saying these nice bro
okay I run or door or door face yak door
yeah the nicest guy in the world it's
only sold in America from 91 to 94 see
it was called the vignette naked they
listen there was the black person a
little baby bow radius port that bigger
know that that there was no 90 mile
radius a black person and the one black
person they hire them to be the finance
manager at the Acura store and then they
gave him a bigger so the white dude to
sit there they were racist and they'd go
look at that [ __ ] big [ __ ]
I thought we just sit there go there's
only embolden I erase it [ __ ] those P
no it's a no that's why they had all the
problem for the football players there's
[ __ ] like that
quick we do 8000 podcast last two
podcast we said that we're like 18
because it's true it's not a racist word
we're usually I'm not using a racist
term at all I was repeating it with what
yeah no no I'm just repeating what they
were saying you know I'm saying I mean
that means why would they make that
obviously what did the car look like to
you have and that's right and it was a
smaller whatever it was a smaller
version of the [ __ ] card and put him
on the map oh the what's the car that
put him on the map well they just looked
so old now Ford or whatever that was
oh yeah that looks like a Datsun yeah
Integra Akira or is it the Acura it I
had a two-door hack your entire I should
call it the act no right little Integra
with the [ __ ] it was tremendous it
had the best [ __ ] stereo system in
the world had what if my brother Jim
wheeler [ __ ] for [ __ ] book oh
really and then we got like eleven five
from the bank we chopped up a nickel
apiece you know I was dog always will
and [ __ ] deal cuz he gave it to me
from book but it was worth more the
stereo they had paid the kid like eight
thousand for the car he told me if you
just put five over on the thing I'll
sell you the car right down to the banks
that's why I did it all perfectly and
they paid off to a thousand dollars to
Colorado I just let that car in a corner
I just left them on the corner dog I was
like I owed I had no insurance yeah so I
hadn't made a payment and [ __ ] I used
to hide the car and on the bushes every
night I had to hide the car three blocks
away and the [ __ ] camouflage you
parked your car night three block all
they were looking for big they were
looking for their tarp on it or whatever
oh no I will talk to some guys garage I
told my had a problem he would let me
park him then he parked outside so the
tow truck that knocked the door down
I was going through hell I was a
starting comedy yeah I was in my third
year second year comedy all the money I
was making was paying an attorney enough
to keep the Wolves off me from my
ex-wife I was committed to calm me at
that point 93 I was like in like that's
it this is what I want to do so it was
just a rough patch I had it was just a
really rough patch and I just left a
call in and you know what years living
with it my credit that ain't nothing
there so it's crazy I thought I'll add
two cars dissolved get the papers but I
know I owed money up I had a car in 83
that I bought off one of those buy here
pay here and the bank Bob and I left her
143rd Street how the 31st Street in the
snowstorm one that came back three days
later they picked him like a chicken
bone
I was just pay was down to the frame I'm
bricks I never said nothing I didn't
call a cop I just got on the plane to
Colorado and dug that thing still hasn't
popped over my credit that I got like a
perfect brother store now and I got my
Amex back and I banged Amex for years
then when I was going through a divorce
I would drive up to a casino and you
can't get a cash advance from Amex
unless you go to a casino in those days
oh really why because the [ __ ] pit
boss are calling American Express
themself always he needs a nickel Wow
yeah and then in the 90s and to earth in
the 90s if your your car if your car had
a $5,000 limit and you went to Las Vegas
you just call the pit boss so a pit boss
would up your [ __ ] little card you
know that no I know I would go to
Atlantic City
yeah but we'd have to play we were under
21 yeah forget our IDs chalk and stuff
so we just wanted to win cash we weren't
looking for big big wins something then
we didn't have to like go in and sign
paperwork for a couple hundred bucks
that's all we were looking for but I
didn't realize that you needed like if
you needed to get a cash advance you
needed to talk to someone a [ __ ] pit
boss or a dealer or someone like that to
get you a cash advance [ __ ]
picked it your cash event they call the
card for you bump your limit and get
your cash advance damn that's how much
strength ahead like in the 90s eighties
the [ __ ] to see
Las Vegas well you can still do it now
he would know of somebody at the company
like the millennia come to Miriam Miriam
Joe over your yeah ceases now society a
nice guy big play I've been coming here
for about four years
it's got 50,000 lives crowd I went up
with 75,000 let me see what I could do
yeah okay and then you'd be able to go
you heard they could still do that oh I
had one no I'm making it an advance I
didn't know it makes sense though cuz
the casino partnership and the probably
will cover the losses like well I will
just have him owe us like they they they
probably like I'm I wouldn't be
surprised
yeah I just ruin it makes sense I just
want you gambling why are you spending
money in my fifth year Tommy for your
comment I'll get to a comedy club and
somebody would go something just called
him for you call this number
I don't thought that's HBO that's an
agent and I call him back in a sec hey
Joey Sam from [ __ ] discover oh my
[ __ ] you have no idea how many places I
would go then they call me you never had
student loans or anything did you I mean
besides like they came after you Phil's
pals and [ __ ] like that or no no no
those are just like oh yeah came back to
me about seven years ago for the student
loan oh they did they found you oh yeah
seven years ago
yeah would they try to pop you if you do
I mean oh but it before Can I grab one
of those too oh holy [ __ ]
seven years ago that's a while after two
[ __ ] I skip there's no statute of
limitations on that no not a lot student
loan then they will [ __ ] hunt you
down
listen if you die your wife is
responsible yeah I thought that student
loan
there's a big voice article year to ago
about people who are leaving the country
and just never coming back but they're
not gonna pay their student loans until
get arrested if they ever come back to
America seriously
yeah they don't dental [ __ ] around you
get a letter as soon as they see
something listen I didn't pay taxes from
91 she's two thousand like [ __ ] three
my wife god bless her talk me into going
to your Harris and I've said it a
thousand times
there was a nicest people in the world
but I'm gonna tell you guys something
you don't have to pay taxes don't you
know it's like if you make 30 G's a year
all I tell you is wheeler-dealer and
you're making cash and to pay taxes I'm
gonna tell you something if you're
making money they know it if you're
making deposits and cashing checks they
know it and they're in time they'll come
get you
they'll come get you when you make money
one time that's what though she they
told me that I wasn't responsible from
ninety one day you'd only go back seven
years those years it doesn't matter I
made I made no money one year I made
money the other [ __ ] seven years were
$8,000 years in 1996 I made an eighty
nine hundred dollars in 1995 I made like
nine thousand dollars one of those years
I made 72 because I made 60,000
December's working for a sports betting
service I made $12,000 one year you know
delivering Chinese food trying to just
put angles together but all those years
doesn't make any I mean like $20,000 and
3,000 won you know you were [ __ ] about
9,000 109 thousand dollars when you
start making money they will reach out
and touch you remember that then reach
out and touch somebody what was that
they'll reach out and touch you they
know exactly where you are especially
now especially today yeah now you can't
go anywhere you know when I was doing
all this crazy [ __ ] remember we were
still you know I was telling these guys
a story the other day that had a friend
who used to was I telling AJ or you
about my buddy with the with the ATM
cart then he would close accounts yeah
who was I tell was that Tony was a day
about he was [ __ ] going to a bank but
mm leave it there for six months and
take a two thousand dollar bank loan on
a book loan on it on the 2000 so he
would take two thousand and then in
those days the computer systems weren't
fast enough so Woodland Hills in Studio
City so he would walk into Studio City
Bank of America at 2:59 and close the
account and get the two thousand back in
2000 back
shoot up the woollen hills by five and
close the account because the computers
would move fast enough and then there
was that processor they caught him me
lady in a linen Kaji out but now you
can't do that you know over the you know
this I'll do a background check two
months ago for a passport this [ __ ] on
there that's not even mind really all
this cocaine arrest I never got arrested
for cocaine but how many Jose Diaz is on
there yeah but Louise why did you say
that cuz my first American Express card
or though that I I got a new one you
know they think the day comes up I had a
new one probably five years ago and yet
I don't I looked at a number of whatever
and all of a sudden I'm using every
guy's like man it's this it's crazy how
old you discard thinks you are a you
know undisguised presages member since
yeah minded member since in the 88 and
my dad as the exact same name is aya
and he had he was a member since 88 so
the card they sent me was my card but
they must they had his name and they had
member since 88 so now I'm you know I'm
a [ __ ] child trying to you know
getting it so I I said that um I go you
guys this is my card right nut sitting
on this shit's not going to my dad's
bill is no no we [ __ ] up we just you
know we looked the name and that was it
I was like oh [ __ ] but yeah I can
imagine that Jose Diaz has many many
different no citations against them but
then the [ __ ] like I did a punish [ __ ]
from 81 to 85 that's good like I don't
start coming up in the computer like I
had an arrest in Bergen County that's
not up there but there was a couple of
arrests of whether those arrests if you
don't get in trouble for six months it's
cleaning off your I could out like six
of those but there was a couple other
ones that you know I know they should be
on there then no way on that how close
you two getting it all taken care of
not close Allah
I just took up the war than Washington
State but it's a nun will have me I want
and I'm gonna come get me yeah surrender
so where I stalemate yeah they just want
money they just want me to pay a fine
that's it that's done I think the Idaho
warrant is null and void I think I know
finally gave up that looks like with
punchaysun Joey yes we did it was a
different time
yeah I was a different you know
something weird happened I don't know if
you guys read the papers it's really
[ __ ] with me the last couple of days
I'm gonna talk about them we'll get the
[ __ ] out of here I got things to do
people to see this thing about anything
Bourdain's girl [ __ ] what about her I
mean her about this this is beautiful
she's one of the early accusers of
Harvey Weinstein but it just got
released that she's getting sued she
settled she settled for raping a 17 year
old kid on a set one night what her she
did yeah and you know I told my wife I
go we look what people don't really
understand across the country is that
Hollywood let's stuff the scratch Wow
this what's that expression they say
about women
there's no wrath angry woman hell hath
no fury like a scorned woman scorned
woman the potato there's a lot of men in
Hollywood the bitter but think how many
a woman they're gonna [ __ ] better you
know there's a bunch of women that suck
dick and got success but there's one
that sucked [ __ ] just got plain lied to
you know I just bumped into a comment
from 20 years ago about two months ago
and it was great to see her in the whole
thing but she sucked her way out of this
town you know you know like you ever see
somebody in your friends living you
never had nothin to do with her
what you just see you're not on you're
like you sucked your way out of this
town you know I went to prison I did
something wrong Steve was easy I got
locked up when I paid my dues Society
and I got judged you know how to get
judged and all this [ __ ] but hmm at the
same time I don't I have daughters and I
have a wife and I have friends I have
daughters and I understand the whole me
to project but you really have to think
of the whole thing and if there's smoke
there's fire
you know before you [ __ ] throw a rock
you better make sure you don't live in a
glass [ __ ] house
I mean okay that's number one the most
painful interview I've seen so far is
Matt Lauer when he's interviewing Bill
O'Reilly just literally like you don't
you're the head of the network you're
the face of the network you don't think
these accusers have and then for him to
be a month later it's like how do you do
that interview it's how do you do that
interview knowing that you you know it's
got to come down the other way we live
hot weird [ __ ] tub we live in a weird
this is always a made a payout our job
read much award this 380,000 to the kid
yeah and she's one of the early accusers
was it it was it uh um like he was like
was he like drugged or what something my
dad or was he just like I was just
seventeen was on the set he was
seventeen in 2013 now hey somebody
should smack the [ __ ] out of him yeah
he's got to be something more subtle
God's kid because you know what's he
doing they jet d'eau sucked his dick off
like she but he could tell she got busy
she's nasty and you know the age of
consent in California is eighteen so
maybe that's why that's all really but
yeah yeah right after she did got a
movie together or something
yeah after but he went after her right
after she started talking about Harvey
Weinstein oh wow okay yeah you gotta
make sure your house is clean before you
start pointing fingers
I try to gonna check your [ __ ] closet
time the time rather those some bones I
always do just look and listen man
that's why by I don't get down when
people you know they talk [ __ ] about the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] you do or I done or
whatever it's like [ __ ] I don't give
a [ __ ] of you like you you have to know
it like your house is all [ __ ]
cleaned up you've done all your homework
you're perfect you know some the thing
that gets me the most about this town is
I was a criminal
I [ __ ] used a gun if you're gonna do
something
guys don't use guns they're like [ __ ]
little wormy [ __ ] dudes you know and
my point before was being this I've done
a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] we were at the
store when don't I said a lot of bad
[ __ ] at the store I seen a woman get put
through a lot of [ __ ] at the store
absolutely
I seen a woman walk into situations at
the store I saw the bad crazy stuff at
the store you know I raised my hand on
some nights there was some crazy [ __ ]
that won all of that but I saw a woman
get eaten up in this town and then you
know you try to pull him beside you like
them as a comic and you're like Amen
don't do that
[ __ ] you you know who you thought oh and
then they got I saw women that try so I
know a lot of female comics that used
that power but at the end comedy always
wins at the end if you can't be funnier
those titties and that [ __ ] and then
all that [ __ ] goes away and I saw it I
saw I saw wouldn't do it
you know I saw one go through it you
know there was a girl at the store when
I first got to the store she would suck
your dick for a spot in the belly room
tell you yeah I tell you yeah I'll suck
your dick responsibility like are you
[ __ ] crazy I'll get you on stage
yeah hold on one second don't go nowhere
talk to this chick yeah real quick you
know I mean it was that crazy at the
store yeah so when you heat or when all
this [ __ ] went on I looked at it from
with you know and I how he wants is a
piece of [ __ ] in my book uniform yeah
but we all know he was doing that
everybody don't everybody was in on it
they were all in on it the agents know
it was like a joke how do we [ __ ] around
when we're together when you know what
sitting there is men three guys you know
when when three guys are sitting
together by themselves what do you think
we're talking about [ __ ] cars yeah
when three animals are sitting together
they're talking about that conquest
that's what they do they talk about that
conquest three classless [ __ ] guys
we're sure there's a lot more class
guys no I than classy guys mm-hmm bro I
have people that suck my dick I've never
said nothing all that was that nothing
yeah people that say don't listen I'm
gonna suck your dick but don't say
nobody could and you're like this is the
best [ __ ] in the world I know let me
say something everybody I want yeah you
don't say no silent you know what I
won't say nothing you're absolutely
right I know how to keep my much but
these guys that have to tell everyone on
question so you didn't mean to tell me
Harvey Weinstein they were told guys
come here for a second [ __ ] roses
whatever name it sucks a tremendous pipe
or whatever they change a chitchat it's
plenty people so they all know they all
know you know Harvey goes to a party
she's a hot 20 year old who's her agent
to come in for a second send her into my
office tomorrow
he knows that agent knows exactly what's
going down you know not one agent was
mentioned that sent all these women I
would attack the agents I would make the
agents liable go hey man you sent me to
that [ __ ] office and [ __ ] Godzilla
stuck it up my ass
you know the truth Lee they say the joke
I used to yell at my agent if they send
me to the wrong building
I used to call my I can you guys get
your [ __ ] together but the truth is a
story is easy there's a lot of people
who know what they're walking into
this town is not there's a lot of people
who don't want to do the work on this
truck Lynette
okay don't want to do the [ __ ] work
and I guarantee there's women that come
on hang on I'll suck a dick you tell me
that that's not true that's the truth
no I'm saying it is I'd also think that
some people think it's their only way
that you know I'm not that good and this
is the only way I'm gonna be able to
write so we saw it we saw it I saw it at
the store yeah and then one night coming
back from the store with Lee and just
tell him stories that I got to the point
when my body was shaken we were outside
it was warm weather I just tell them to
call me you know just
[ __ ] that I had forgotten about that
your mind gets exercised as you're
talking mm-hmm and you remember if yeah
sexual and crazy situations and you know
and I'll tell you what like I've never
really been like a [ __ ] and and I
wanted to tell this story on the podcast
when I was 13 I want a Cuban dudes and
they were animals
you know Cuban dudes are animals yeah
the white dudes and I will bloom it more
classy but the Cuban dudes like Alan
make out and grab a Teddy Z should try
them really [ __ ] though you know I
didn't have a father give me like
guidance so when that was at this girl's
house I know I grew up with we all grew
up with this girl we all go to a house
and we're in the house and we're
watching like I said in my life there
was this girl another girl I came home
but that went to a Catholic school we
crumpled it but I hadn't seen her in the
world of like holy [ __ ] she look good oh
my god and we had I noticed it's like
maybe the third day I moved to North
Bergen I became friends with her and her
brother and her brother I think join the
army got shot one night he came back
home on leave and got shot on a drug
deal or something like that but they
lived in her neighborhood but she went
to a Catholic school and I was a little
[ __ ] savage at the time I didn't know
nothing about nothing nothing out of
control like I didn't know why they take
and she didn't have a bra and she had
like a shirt up yeah
and the tit was popping out I was like I
could hang it what are you gonna do I
couldn't [ __ ] take it
what do you do and I just told I said
kept with me downstairs see if I care
but she didn't know she thought we're
gonna meet this smoke a joint yeah
downstairs and I still smell slow gonna
join whatever I told I said you know I
started give another typical wife [ __ ]
I've always had a crush on here we
started making out and I have about 1/4
a tip like the tip was out I grab the
tip you know and she let me suck it for
a couple of minutes and then afterward
she started crying like she was 13
though I was 13 yeah she put a tip back
in issues she's I can't believe you know
I'd let you do this I feel terrible and
she started crying on that first I'm
like what are you doing I got mad for
about two minutes but for some reason I
saw a little girl in her and that's when
I discovered section arrest
that's my section arrived from the store
mm-hmm like just seeing her cry because
she hadn't given me her tip the first
time this is the first time she ever why
she just went out to experiment she ran
into a wolf yeah yeah well yeah I'm
gonna say
you have to experiment and you saw the
in you still had enough innocence I
think the CD yes since in her and say
yeah girl is not like rejecting me she's
just scared right now and she's got like
saying like it's you're an [ __ ] or
foot but a little more like just like
I'm in its uncomfortable situation that
I you know didn't know I was getting
myself into
I didn't know yeah I didn't know is
that's a great I mean well look that's a
great lesson again especially and be
able to lock into it and that friend
yeah wasn't a girl at a bar so you
weren't trying yeah you know no like a
cool relationship she was sending me a
message every time she bent over mm-hmm
and she even had like funnel tits like
that it's worth big developed yet they
were just go forward like a she was
beautiful she has a beautiful girl she
had grown up to be a beautiful [ __ ]
girl you know I she was 13 out of 13 but
that was the first time I saw a girl
jump set like that and it bothered me
and I knew right there I knew that
that's it like she didn't say no she
just pulled away because she was a
Catholic [ __ ] girl
and she's like my brother's gonna find
out you know my father like she was just
ashamed she went on to date some [ __ ]
tow truck dude why soon with the years
later who were the filthy dick [ __ ]
[ __ ]
but yeah all this year was I learned
something you learn that's great I
really did learn something from that we
have heared and I'm like well I dated
that girl in New York in the seventh
grade like we just dry out odd time all
the time I suck their titties and that's
it that made me get look back like
that's how weak I was at that age like
that I got left back from her just dry
humping me like I didn't plan it and she
told me I want to wait and I would just
take it yeah I would take what you can
get I was just happy that people would
would dry hump with me [ __ ] in not
doggy
everybody keeps time you want to start
this game with vodka oh yeah I'm
starting I'm gonna do it dry around the
end of the week
just practicing yeah here's a deal
here's why it's not just gambling on
getting to gamble it's gambling because
now that's legal everywhere it's sort of
like the taboos off told me that it's
legal well now you can go into it used
to just be Vegas you can get a bit
better
sportsbook that's what you when you want
to gamble on the Emmys or the hot dog
eating contest or a [ __ ] baseball
game you can't just go to the OTB you
got to go to light you used to have to
go just to Vegas they had they were the
only one with a sports book then jerseys
had the big lawsuit and now they won
Supreme Court because they the whole
thing was you can't have a sports book
and a professional sports team so that's
why Atlantic City couldn't have a sports
book for all those years so now now that
anyone can have a sports book they're
everywhere so you can literally go down
to your local sports book and gamble on
anything or you can do it online that's
another option so my thing is this it's
not just gonna be football it's not just
gonna be sports not just be baseball
it's gonna be the week of the Emmys I'm
gonna have someone come on we're gonna
talk about the categories we're gonna
see the odds and we're gonna gamble and
bet on that we'll talk about that for
the week we're gonna have all these
different bets building up so that we're
gonna have payoffs and have to like you
know have either it's not gonna be
monetary bets but like Shane bets and
things like that I'm gonna bet you know
baseball Yankees Red Sox say they got a
World Series game coming up whatever it
will do something like that so it's
gonna be all arenas politics sports
anything so it's not just gambling to
gamble on money but I do want to have
some experts on because like baseball I
don't know how to bet baseball it's a
thousand different ways so I want to
have one someone to talk about that you
know saying to exploit other people had
a bit base yeah had a bet baseball had a
bet you know what's the high to bet golf
when you play golf there's all these
different games you can play Woolf last
man and all these different things you
can do so have someone on to talk about
the different games you can play like
what was the last what was the first
thing you ever gambled for me blackjack
for me professional sheets that's the
first game what do you mean like foot
football sheets people give you all like
these all over da Phil pick the team's
how to pick for for for for ten bucks
for a dollar yeah that's a five beg you
like 13 though that's the first time I
learned and then you gotta pick collar
decides like card games like at the
house like oh my grandfathers and uncles
would play card games and stuff I didn't
like losing I don't like paying on
Thursday so that's what got me thank God
like I made a decision
if I'm gonna pay a book it might as well
store cover yes my decision her yeah and
they these three I was like wait a
second I can't gamble and smoke out
I'll tell you what I will do I won't
gamble and smoked up obvious I'll get
something out of it I didn't like paying
a bookie every [ __ ] week I always
thought about doing a sports betting
podcast then I have a friend a dear
friend that that's his expertise oh
really
Danny really cool oh that's his
expertise of a they did a segment on him
lhb oh well 97 that's what I told Justin
great oh yeah I go I should put but
Danny loses Hoboken but we could Skype
he does his own thing
oh it does you know he's tight with the
ref oh okay the ref did our show who are
we on okay
and then he's tight with this other guy
that has a sports betting thing out of
Philly Johnny I follow a month where the
good guy really good guy but I'm in with
all those guys I just for years you know
Donaghy around yeah oh god ah McGee
those guys for years people have you
know because I dunno but I don't know I
don't know nobody no nobody knows that's
why everybody knows that's what I was
gonna do if like people are like oh you
should do a fantasy football podcast or
whatever and I'm like did the market
sort of saturated with that but also
like I used to go on those fantasy
football expert podcasts and I used to
send him like you mean nobody the
ball-shaped
[ __ ] crazy it bounces weird nobody
knows the ball bounces this way the ball
bounces that way you're right you're
right who's who's an expert there's no
[ __ ] expert
there's no one knows I mean there are
dudes that do their homework there are
dudes I know who kick well in the
[ __ ] weather and which way this is
going on but nobody really knows now
though now because of the whole gambling
thing the NFL but one of the leaks is
the first one to sign you can bet the
bet at the [ __ ] stadium that game
probably the Raiders yeah so you can now
have you can bet at the game on that
[ __ ] game that you're at right there
so now they have like NFL guys and and
and you know they have gambling guys in
these [ __ ] locker rooms I'm just
saying
before long there's a reason why all
these spreads and all these numbers are
so [ __ ] close every single time I
know yeah every single [ __ ] time
these guys know so yeah those guys are
experts the guys that could call the
lines and stuff like that but as far as
like fantasy football or [ __ ] that's
not really but the guys that really make
the lines it's like seven or eight dudes
that know exactly what the [ __ ] is going
on and they trick it but it's um because
you're if you're if you're a casino
think about you got to find someone
that's going to lay the odds for your
casino to make sure you don't [ __ ]
lose money I mean there's probably seven
guys in the world
yeah there's seven no but this bar we
can I can I got a couple guys think they
see it coming
they [ __ ] trick you they're they're
geniuses women's that's the line that
stats is a genius but limo are wise man
once told me it's Lisa was a starting
quarterback and he lost Petros was
playing the game yeah and he was a loser
and so was Michael Jordan was back again
nothing he was losing what makes you
think you could pick a [ __ ] game once
I heard that I was like you got me that
I think it's you gotta have separation
those guys have too much skin in the
game
Jordan's too emotional he doesn't want
to lose it doesn't I think the seven
guys that know how to do it they don't
give a [ __ ] it's a math it's a it's
either a gut feeling that they just
believe their gut and if they're wrong
that was a fluke thing or that some sort
of math problem that they go this is
what the answer is I don't give a f--- I
listen I'd be like the receiving side of
the hook for years the hook means you
know the line says seven when you call
your local bookie it's a seven and a
half because more people bet the next
and we are the [ __ ] so they move it
over Detroit Pistons so they move all
this [ __ ] like I know all about that
local stuff I used to do it myself I
used to have my coke dealer this is
Jenna gambler at three cambios not one
of my cook this is Jenna again well so I
set him up during football season I call
him on Fridays and start telling him
what to pick and then that would I call
him Sunday and oh I'm really liking this
game
I know it was loose Oh God and then he
would call me Sunday no can you get a
better than I would sit on it and he
would pay me with cocaine that night I
gotta go pick up the money to take
though for me god damn it how do you do
I'd set him up on Thursday with what the
back but I knew they were losers and
every week I was right he bet against me
or whatever
oh my yeah I bet I just knew it that's
how I got free coke on Sundays when host
at the store
Jesus gay nights that's how I got free
coke that was my Sunday they look to set
him up in the [ __ ] and I would even
koala me go he you got a book he would
calm you got a book yeah it'll be
pointing right back I'd set him up wait
five minutes I got one guy said seven
and a half but you gotta bet a hundred I
would always keep him low and [ __ ] like
he was going about five hundred none on
this guy first time a hundred hours just
in case he long cut just in case yeah
yeah but he was the kiss of death he
couldn't pick a [ __ ] up the mush I see
you know I just saw so many guys that
now if I like something overwhelming and
I'm in Vegas I'll bet it mm-hmm
but if not I want to have someone to
talk about podcasts what was funny
because bet on pot who's gonna have the
most hits this week on their podcast I
don't know whatever it is like you can
have a topic about any it's like doesn't
have to be sports at all that's why I
like it it's just like people have
opinions and they feel like they're like
no [ __ ] you I know what I'm talking
about
alright let's bet on it you're wrong you
wear a bikini on the podcast next week
I'm wrong I'll grow a [ __ ] mustache
for a month whatever we'll pull like the
Triple E things spin my mouth yeah maybe
not get that filthy but yes sort of like
looking crazy away those guys yeah those
diseases well you know Ari and I got a
long-standing one it's it's it's almost
a year old now when the whole Louie
thing happened I told Ari oh that I'm
like that's it it's gonna be a while
before we see him again this is October
of seventeen last year and he goes uh
he'll be on stage by the end of the year
I go are you out of your [ __ ] mind
you think he's gonna go on stage I go
what comedy clubs putting them on stage
I don't forget if you want
I understand up I would have no problem
with him going on stage but what if the
waitresses walk out what if there's a
protest out in front of the [ __ ]
thing this is Rick right when it
happened no I go i underst
allowed to know fine I go he'll be on
stage we'll bet on when he's gonna be on
stage so it ends up being - by the end
of this year if he doesn't step on stage
we did the bag of bets on that on the
podcast so he'd reach in and the thing
we pulled out was we the loser has to
act in a three-page gay porno that the
winner writes and there could be nil
- no [ __ ] but it's gonna be pretty
you know terrible and Neal Brennan's
gonna direct it and then we're gonna put
it up on so you got four months for him
duck together stay four months
shall we go into the comedy so I know
he's been going but he has not gotten on
stage he has two gears that stay not get
on stage
December 31st 2018 and then it's gonna
be terror to have three different ideas
for the three-page arc I want already go
through on the porno but none of you
nervous he's gonna get on stage did what
are you nervous ladies get on well I see
you know you see articles like like Adam
eBay sends me an article like cuz he's
my ears on the ground I go if Becky
starts telling you like start clearing I
go you let let me know first because I
got to start preparing myself mentally
but so I have ears on the ground but so
does Ari no one's more embedded in the
New York comedy scene than all right so
he'll know first but as far as LA is
concerned and then I have like people
talking to me like Fitzsimmons is like
well I think he's gonna start in
Australia this account if I go yeah
stage but he's like I think over there
he'll start there cuz it's a little bit
looser you know his reputation perhaps
over theirs might be a little bit better
so there's a whole like where is it
gonna start so let me ask you a question
yeah how would you handle blue easy
I'd guess what I would've got on stage
the next day I well how would a guy that
stays the next night all I can say is
I'm not in the same situation I was in
something somewhat said took me a month
I'll tell you something but I mean the
first time you get on the [ __ ] stage
and face the horse there's one you'd
done yeah you have to face the horse now
my whole beef would this whole me -
thing this whole thing that how will
wrap this up is well then went to court
I got accused I got having this point
against me and you having this one
against me in today's world you could
just say something and we're done and I
don't like that I do not like that power
that that seed the first time somebody
says something I'm gone I got a blog up
I got a thousand things coming up I
wouldn't just hide I would say yeah this
is what I did was awful ten years ago
does it [ __ ] really matter now if you
don't think I changed in the last ten
years then you don't know then you
didn't change mm we've all [ __ ] the
chains you have twenty ten years you
change course so for you to hold
somebody accountable like that to end
this career it's not fair it's not fair
no man especially after this [ __ ] our
heads no thing this is what I'm talking
about a couple months ago they accused
the Nerdist you've been around the
Nerdist yeah there's more like he's a
[ __ ] animal too you know and I know
that girl I know her well I knew did
spider-man two with that girl oh really
yeah yeah she was on the podcast and I
don't on the final we had 14 years old
and I'm when I read that thing I didn't
read that you know why because he'll has
no scoring like an angry [ __ ] woman
okay and there's a lot of people who
walk around man this [ __ ] town
there's a lot of people were happy
because they depended on their talent I
had a big problem with a dependent on
their talent yep if you depend on your
talent then you don't have to do those
creepy things I've done a thousand
creepy things in my [ __ ] time but let
me tell you some when it comes to
stand-up comedy the reason why Rogan
talks to me is because I don't [ __ ]
around this is what we do this is
there's no shortcuts there's no well he
said this there's never been that in my
world I know that the answer is getting
on a stage and working your writing
that's it mm-hmm anything else is
background music well if you go there
and hang out there you know there if you
make out with this broad I never
believed that I never believed I never
bought none of those stories and that's
the [ __ ] problem that a lot of people
come in mistake that [ __ ] for work and
then guess what you come and go yeah
you come and go and you gotta put
yourself through the aggravation to do
what sleep with some guy suck some bad
balls by now I look at my balls at
Bentley go can you imagine making some
twenty bucks
girl suck these rotten [ __ ] nuts to
get the moon now like after I read about
Harvey like look at my dick it looks
like a [ __ ] science project you look
at my dick it's got scars it holds me
from [ __ ] I used to put drugs in my dick
then come back clean and [ __ ] and drain
on my dick it looks like a real
oh my god I got rashes from [ __ ]
jujitsu and [ __ ] down imagine putting
your nut in somebody's mouth and you
acting in a movie and little I gonna ask
him walking around like you got you know
there's a way now and all those people
who suck the dick they're not around it
I guarantee it another round yeah -
another round it's it's such a talent
this time with men and it stands on its
own it really does yeah and all the
[ __ ] short cutters that gun all the
shortcut is a gun
I totally all the time I've seen people
come and go I remember going to diners
with these people and having a
three-hour you beaten are there plans on
how they were gonna be comedies comics
and they just fall apart and none of
them were to be funny it was always like
first I'm gonna do this I'm gonna read
this book I go I'm gonna go to this club
I'm gonna go to this premiere
listen funny is funny you gotta work on
it and with that it's always a pleasure
to have you I love your podcast hear me
this book gave me this book don't forget
he's back on it you're back on back on
in every week
no probs remember Thursday sold out and
[ __ ] tomorrow sold out in Huntsville
Saturday sold out or you got tickets for
Friday night in Nashville so I'll see
you [ __ ] this week in Nashville
were you at next uh La Jolla comedy
store last weekend in September
oh [ __ ] shed headin in La Jolla oh [ __ ]
and up to Edmonton in the first weekend
of October Abdullah high in December oh
you are I love that I do it once a year
now it's so much you know what why that
will be released organize why [ __ ]
around I love it thank you for listening
guys don't forget the church is brought
to you by for hems comm a one-stop shop
for hair loss skin care and sexual
wellness for men
have you seen more forehead than ever
before has someone mentioned that you
have a bald spot that wasn't there
before have you
mr. Paulo head and your brush on your
comb when the bottom of your shower have
you fixed your hair lately and just said
where has my hair gone
listen go-to for hems dot-com right now
I'll tell you why
why because there's no waiting room
there's no awkward person doctor visits
you save hours by going to for hems calm
answer a few quick questions upload some
photos and the doctor will prescribe you
the prescription meds that you need and
they shipped directly to your door hims
will also help you with you know
edie problems let's say you're going out
on a Friday night you're gonna go have
some party some drinks why take a chance
go to him calm right now
and they'll help you out it's a
tremendous thing look the leaves going
bald he knows a little I wish I had for
him I don't you wish you had for hims
not when you need it me I'm losing my
head but guess what I don't need it no
more
there's I'm 55 what direction am I going
I'm going
but you guys ball this could be optional
thanks to science so do me a favor
alright one favor going to for hems calm
right now my listeners the church family
will get a trial month the hymns for
five hours you and Joey fine fine hours
today right now while supplies last see
the website for Ford beat for full
details this will cost you hundreds if
you went to a doctor or pharmacy uncle
Joey's on a take care you gonna go to
forums calm slash Joey Jo ey that's for
hems calm fo are hims calm slash Joey I
got four hens calm slash Joey don't have
hair loss and no more Edie understand me
you don't want cousin Joey's taking K
number two on it
listen from the shrimp export to the
shrimp tech immune so that Mexican
chocolate whey protein that is just
delicious on it is always there to cover
the spread
alpha brain hundred-percent money-back
guarantee if you don't like the product
who does that and this with Dan AIDS
they got kettlebells they got way to
vest they had a bunch of stuff I can't
cover you there as far as supplements
are concerned
you get 10% off from uncle Joey go to on
it leather check out press Church boom
and get 10% delivered right to your
house alright I want to thank Steve
Brothers easy
I want to think that you don't forget
Nashville Friday night that's all we
take is we got left this weekend that's
it and that dad I love you [ __ ]
stay black have a great weekend we'll be
back Monday morning ready a [ __ ] Rock
take this [ __ ] meal leave